ça vous tente ces images elles ont été
filmées à compiègne en picardie
l'imaginarium festival ce festival
j'en suis le fondateur et le premier
président ouais j'ai 26 ans je suis
ingénieur comme bientôt la majorité
d'entre vous je pense et j'ai une
passion pour la musique
alors je suis pas musicien je suis pas
un artiste
j'ai une passion pour les coûte jeu
j'arpente les salles de concerts et les
festivals à la recherche de les changes
que cela génère et donc pendant mes
études d'ingénieur
je me suis posé la question suivante je
me suis dit pourquoi ne pas rendre ce
qu'on me donne
pourquoi ne pas organiser moi même un
événement musical de grande ampleur y
avait à ce moment là un ville invite
dans mon école et dans ma ville donc à
ce moment-là j'ai 20 ans j'ai beaucoup
d'énergie une bonne bande de copains
donc je présente un peu l'idée à mes
amis jordi les filles les gars est ce
que ça vous dit de vous lancer dans une
grande aventure
ce qu'on organiserait pas nous mêmes un
festival de musique au départ
l'enthousiasmé est réel
en effet mes potes sont pour la plupart
également amateurs de musique
on a déjà tous vécu un événement qui
nous a marqués donc je décide
d'organiser un brainstorming avec ces
mêmes potes on se retrouve on se
retrouve dans un appart dans un salon
puis on décide d'afficher au mur des
feuilles blanches sur les murs blancs et
on y va on échange sur ce qu'on souhaite
faire
tout y passe un objectif du projet
format style de musique le concept et
c'est alors un brainstorming c'est super
je suis fier d'être un peu créatif et
d'avoir un sujet qui vous plaît et les
idées fusent
donc là on met pas bien longtemps à
remplir toutes ces feuilles au mur c'est
super on sort de ce fait de ce
brainstorming plein d'espoir sauf que le
brainstorming
il ya quand même un vilain défaut c'est
que quand vous faites un brainstorming
vous émettez pas de critiques en fait
c'est le principe même du truc donc en
sortant de ce brainstorming ont décidé
de présenter le projet à nos amis enfin
ceux qui n'étaient pas là
là les réactions elles sont différentes
elles sont variés et les questions sont
nombreuses
quand vous créez un projet vous allez
avoir beaucoup de questions qui vont se
poser les questions qu'on va vous poser
ses questions
elles concernent essentiellement trois
points elle concerne l'expérience
concerne l'argent elle concerne le temps
ces trois points sont à l'origine de
l'abandon de nombreux projets parce que
ce sont des points qui font peur en 2012
qu'en éduquant geste idée j'ai rien de
tout ça dans mon bagage
j'ai pas de contacts j'ai pas d'argent
j'ai un portefeuille d'étudiants et puis
j'ai pas de temps vos agendas sont
j'imagine bien remplie alors on me
chalenge un peu sur ces trois sujets
mais nathan nathan comment tu vas faire
en un an et demi pour créer un festival
tu sais même pas comment s'y prendre
comment tu le finance bah c'est vrai à
ce moment là j'ai aucune réponse à tout
ça j'ai juste un vieux proverbe africain
dans un coin de ma tête qui me dit tout
seul on va plus vite ensemble on va plus
loin
mais bon ce proverbe problème ça là
c'est qu'il faut aller vite et loin on
peut de temps donc moi je me dis c'est
facile on va recruter une grosse équipe
je transpose un peu ce proverbe et je me
dis on va recruter 100 bénévoles on va
séparer le périmètre en un an et demi
heure tout le monde c'est parti on va le
faire c'est là que les difficultés
commencent
alors avec mon futur vice-président on
décide de participer à la journée des
associations de l'école en se disant
qu'on va recruter nos 100 membres de
l'association on se dit on va leur
envoyer du rêve et les gens vont nous
suivre
sauf que là en fait on n'a rien on n'a
pas de nom n'a pas d'image et on n'a
aucune garantie que le projet peut
marcher donc en fait on est derrière une
vulgaire table de cours avec des
feuilles blanches encore une fois en
demandant aux gens d'inscrire leur nom
dessus pour rien vous cacher ça n'a pas
été un franc succès 100 bénévoles
espéraient 15 au final autant vous dire
qu'on n'était pas super satisfait
c'est peu mais ça fait quand même une
équipe projet on peut démarrer la phase
de pré étude étude de marché étude de
faisabilité la gestion de projet pour
les nuls comment créer une asso de 1900
a encore une fois on part de rien et
cette pré études elle est plutôt pro
vente mais force est de constater au
bout de quatre mois qu'on a toujours pas
grand chose n'a pas de lieu pas de date
pas de nom bref pas la folie on sent que
le chemin va être long la route et
patras et et on continue ne me posais la
question en fait mais nathan pourquoi tu
continues pourquoi tu tentes est bas
c'est vrai pourquoi je continue en fait
je me pose la question je m'interroge
c'est pas la première fois en quatre
mois que je m'interroge
mais pour la première fois quand je
m'interroge je vais prendre le problème
dans l'autre sens je me pose la question
suivante je me dis qu'est ce qui se
passe si je le fais pas qu'est ce qui se
passe si vous vous ne faites pas votre
projet
j'ai un rêve il est là devant moi je le
connais et je leur porte à une date
ultérieure en espérant potentiellement
de pouvoir l'ofs leur faire un jour ça
j'en savais rien et finalement à ce
moment là j'ai eu peur j'ai eu peur de
ne pas le faire on parle souvent de
risques quand vous faites un projet on
va vous parler des risques mais on parle
peu du risque à ne pas faire le risque
de ne pas le faire c'est perdre tout le
bénéfice personnel que vous pourrez
tirer de votre projet est-ce qu'il vaut
mieux ne pas le faire plutôt que
d'échouer
est ce que finalement le fait de ne pas
le faire c'était passé à l'échec
bah moi je pense que si ça aurait été un
échec personnel
alors c'est clair un personne ment a
jugé vous auriez jamais entendu parler
de l'imaginaire même festival
et puis moi je serais resté chez moi
tranquille et en revanche dans 40 ans je
serai retraités enfin ça c'est pas sûr
mais supposons que le soin et je
pourrais faire un bilan je me dirai dans
ma vie qu'est ce que j'aurais aimé faire
que je n'ai pas fait assurément à ce
moment là j'aurais repenser à ce
festival et il aurait été tout en haut
de ma liste et à ce moment-là je me dis
hors de question d'avoir de si gros
regrets on y va on y va avec l'équipe on
y va c'est parti
un peu de temps on trouve un lieu une
date un nom on recrute
on arrive à un bouquet 20 artistes
connus internationalement vous irez voir
si ça vous intéresse et donc on a un
budget d'un demi million d'euros quand
même un planning très serré et tous les
six mois
on a trente personnes supplémentaires
qui veulent se greffer au projet on
commence à avoir une identité de groupe
une fierté d'appartenance de la part de
nos membres de l'asso on structure un
peu du coup cette équipe
un bureau restreint un bureau élargi aux
normes des responsables de pôles on
prend les décisions en équipe on forme
une équipe et est donc on avance avec
cette équipe
et alors là j'ai un petit trou mémoire
et donc à ce moment là avec cette équipe
on avance et on essaye de se
professionnaliser
on essaye de se professionnaliser pour
2.1 pour animer l'équipe et deux pour
faire preuve de crédibilité vis-à-vis de
l'extérieur
en effet la crédibilité parlons-en
justement j'ai deux petites anecdotes
sympas sur le sujet alors la première
elle concerne une réunion à la
préfecture qu'on a réalisé elle concerne
la sécurité de l'événement
moi je n'aime pas trop ça la sécurité
mais en tout cas on se fait bombarder de
questions je suis courtier qu'est ce que
vous faites
s'il ya un orage qui se déclare pendant
un concert six chapiteaux s'écroule si
un incendie dans le camping je vous
avoue que là vous savez pas trop préparé
tout genre de questions et sur l'une
d'entre elle répond ben je pense que là
je me fais couper net par une personne
des services de police qui me dit
monsieur gautier ici on n'est pas là
pour penser si vous ne savez pas ce que
vous avancez si vous n'êtes pas sûr de
vos mesures pouvez rentrer chez vous on
arrête l'événement y aura pas de
festival
ça fait mal une grosse claque dans la
joue et on sent qu'on n'a pas trop le
droit à l'erreur
puis la deuxième anecdote elle concerne
un message d'espoir en septembre en
septembre on commence la programmation
musicale de l'événement une des clés de
voûte du projet et je me fais appeler
par un gros producteur local qui demande
à me rencontrer à nous rencontrer
on accepte et on se retrouve autour d'un
café
et demande qu'on lui présente un peu le
projet est rapidement rapidement il nous
dit qu'il souhaiterait injecter de
l'argent dans le festival
cent cinquante mille euros je sais plus
mais pour nous c'était une grosse somme
d'argent et on a refusé
on a refusé car on souhaitait rester
maîtres de nos choix et garder notre
identité
on est quand même ressortis le sourire
aux lèvres en se disant tiens t'as vu
comment ça être crédible comment ça
crédible et du coup on a franchi les
étapes pas à pas comme ça avec du culot
de l'audace et puis ça devenait
compliqué d'aller en cours ça devenait
compliqué de dormir on était stressés on
avait la pression
et puis et puis arrive le jour j le jour
j en fait il n'y a plus grand chose à
faire vous regardez le résultat d'un an
et demi de travail
vous pouvez presque vous installé dans
votre fauteuil comme comme vous êtes là
et puis voilà finalement ces deux jours
sont très bien passées l'événement s'est
parfaitement déroulé en deux jours on a
acquis un public une réputation
on a conquis les artistes les
partenaires les sponsors les élus alors
il ya un point noir au tableau quand
même c'est qu'on a perdu de l'argent
tout peut pas être parfait et pas de
honte on a perdu de l'argent
depuis cette perte elle a été comblé par
un événement le succès d'un événement
grandissant en 2018
l'imaginarium festival a vécu sa
cinquième édition accueille treize mille
personnes et affiché complet pour la
première fois ça c'est le fruit du
travail du travail de six équipes
pendant six ans que je souhaiterais
remercier d'ailleurs tous ceux qui ont
pris le prix la mer avec moi au début et
e
et alors le fait que ce festival il a
rien d'extraordinaire des îles a rien
d'incroyable pour moi c'est le meilleur
festival de la terre bien sûr je suis
pas forcément objectif sur le sujet mais
ma fierté c'est d'avoir réussi lorsque
lorsque peut y croyez monuments
bénéficient les personnels j'ai pas
gagné un centime sur l'usure le projet
en revanche j'ai appris beaucoup plus
humainement quelqu'un courte sociaux
j'ai plus appris en gestion de projet
qu'avec un cours gestion de projet j'ai
plus appris en management qu'avec un
cours de management
alors on me demande souvent quelle est
la recette du succès en fait il n'y a
pas de recette magique comme ça c'est un
tout c'est beaucoup de travail
c'est une équipe de passionnés c'est de
la rigueur forcément puisse et du culot
et beaucoup d'audace s'élancer le fait
de vous lancer qui dure en fait
uniquement
alors je vous ai ramené un petit objet
alors je sais plus exactement où amy
j'espère que idées dans ma poche ça
c'est toutes mes notes cas où j'ai un
trou super jeux les plus jeunes et plus
facile et la voilà je vais sortie tout
contenu de mes poches et j'ai pas si
vous voyez bien d'objets c'est un bateau
stop j'ai c'est un bateau votre projet
c'est un bateau l'imaginaire festival
c'est un bateau et alors il ya des
différents types de bateaux celui-là
c'est un bateau en papier voir un petit
zodiac et un bateau qui va très vite
vous pouvoir une barque
vous allez devoir ramer un voilier qui
dépend du sens du vent et alors quand
vous allez faire votre trajet en bateau
vous n'allez pas forcément avoir un
grand soleil voire des tempêtes et des
vents contraires
le tout c'est de s'être préparés et
d'attendre que la tempête se calme
l'imaginarium festival quand on imagine
on pense à un gros paquebot le queen
mary je sais pas si vous visualisez
queen mary ses 17 étages des piscines
des restos bref pas mal
et alors pour faire avancer le queen
mary il faut plus de 1000 personnes dans
l'équipage et au départ de notre projet
on n'avait pas du tout l'équipage pour
faire avancer le bateau
pour autant on a commencé la
construction et puis au fur et à mesure
il ya des gens qui sont passés à côté du
bateau du chantier naval qui ont dit
tiens t'as vu finalement il a l'air pas
mal ce bateau si si je voulais bosser
dedans et si je partais en croisière
dessus ça a marché dans deux semaines
c'est le départ de la route du rhum
la route du rhum c'est une grosse course
de bateaux qui a lieu tous les quatre
ans entre saint malo et la guadeloupe
le dernier vainqueur de la route du rhum
il s'appelle loïc peyron il a gagné au
bout de sa septième participation 32 ans
après la première
il avait abordé trois fois sur les
quatre dernières et lors de cette
édition le perron il a relevé un défi
complètement fou trois mois avant le
départ il a changé de bateaux on lui a
proposé prendre un plus gros bateau
alors certes normalement un plus gros
bateau vous ça va plus vite mais pour
autant il ne connaissait pas du tout ce
bateau il aurait pu se dire non on va me
juger si je gagne pas et que j'ai plus
robes à tous finalement il a pris la mer
il a gagné la course et il a explosé le
record de la traversée
pourquoi je vous dis tout ça c'est parce
que je pense qu'on est un peu tous les
skippers de notre ville et est donc ce
qui est sûr c'est que si vous ne prenez
pas la mer vous avez aucune chance
d'arriver au port d'arrivée et encore
moins de chances de gagner la course
on dit souvent que la chance sourit aux
audacieux
c'est une citation qui vient de virgile
de lénine à la base et l'audace et
essayer si vous essayez pas alors pas
n'importe comment bien sûr il faut
vraiment réfléchir mais si vous
n'essayez pas si vous sortez pas de
votre zone de confort vous restez
installé tranquillement dans votre
chaise
vous avez aucune chance d'y arriver on a
tous un jour renoncer à un projet par
peur par crainte par flemme et
finalement dans mon cas les fois où j'ai
essayé ça m'a souvent souri je pense
qu'on a tous une part de da sur nous
alors si j'ai un conseil à vous donner
c'est ne vivait pas dans leur gré prenez
la mer et et lancez-vous
merci
[Applaudissements]